bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est au csa
las vegas juste devant le stand de
samsung ce temps qui est énorme pour
parler de gaulle
le nouvel écran énorme gigantissime qui
présage vraiment de l'avenir de ce que
va être de ce que vont être les écrans
pour samsung en tout cas avec une
technologie qui est entièrement nouvelle
cdu migros genève
[Musique]
samsung a présenté son nouvel écran sans
46 pouces s'appelle the roll seront
simplement parce qu'on a vraiment que
c'est un mur complet un pan de mur est
énorme alors c'est génial avec cet écran
en micro l'aide c'est comment qu'on peut
avoir
les dimensions 2 on peut en faire ce
qu'on veut on peut régler la lumière
comme on le souhaite on a des contrats
ce qui sont impressionnants des couleurs
qui sont vraiment magnifiques
c'est vraiment une technologique est
superbe c'est quelque chose
d'entièrement nouveau le micro l'aide on
a connu effectivement céder on a connu
le led le oled
maintenant voilà le micro l'aide c'est
vraiment le premier écran micro l'aide
au monde
c'est vraiment la nouveauté de sa
mission de cette année c'est un écran
modulaire niekro l'aide vous avez un
design sans borne
lorsque vous êtes dedans il ya vraiment
une sensation d'immersion c'est
gigantissime hyper impressionnant
alors on peut imaginer dans différentes
applications quelque chose plutôt dédié
aux professionnels
on peut imaginer de l'avoir sur des
écrans d'affichage des halls d'hôtels
différentes salles de réunion à part
quelque chose de vraiment magnifique dit
merci avec cette technique peut imaginer
de faire une pièce complète d'être en
immersion complète du sol au plafond
sur les quatre murs faire vraiment ce
qu'on veut alors va y avoir encore
beaucoup de choses autour là ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui c'est une nouvelle
technologie mais on imagine qu'elle va
énormément se développer on va pouvoir
avoir différentes applications dans des
chauves souris auxquelles on ne pense
pas mais ça présage vraiment d'un avenir
et surtout ça montre la capacité à
samsung a su reprendre à innover tout
quand on sait que le bond des
téléviseurs c'est un peu le ou de
l'high-tech roi des nouveautés sur les
téléviseurs on va plemons du téléviseur
se porte bien c'est qu'en règle générale
le monde de la high tech se montrent
plutôt pas mal
alors micro l'aide c'est quoi
une techno qui est basée sur la led ça
j'imagine que vous vous en doutez avec
l'utilisation de matières organiques à
la place de matière inorganique je pense
que parfois contre encore plus dans le
détail parce qu'après c'est vraiment
technique c'est une techno qui est
entièrement nouvelle et tout ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'a vraiment qu'aujourd'hui
nouveau disparaître samsung pour
l'instant soyez tranquilles
les écrans oled ont encore de l'avenir
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui sont
équipés de lcd de l'aide des oled ou
encore comme moi des vieux dinosaures
avec du plasma ça on a vu ça va encore
durer bien longtemps
là on est vraiment sur une découverte
d'une nouvelle technologie
cette technologie rentrer dans nos
foyers mais bien plus tard pour
l'instant on en est encore qu'au tout
début donc n'imaginais pas avoir une
télé micro l'aide chez vous l'année
prochaine dans deux ans à mon avis faut
encore être extrêmement patient et d'ici
là il y aura encore de nouvelles
technologies qui m'arrivait donc est-ce
qu'on retrouvera un jour des écrans
microoled chez soi rien n'est moins sûr
l'avenir nous le dira voilà un peu pour
ce nouvel écran cette nouvelle
technologie micro l'aide ce vol samsung
c'est vraiment impressionnant
moi vous ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous trouvez que cette innovation va
dans le bon sens est ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous trouvé
intéressant d'avoir ces énormes écrans
plats des technologies toujours plus et
toujours plus intéressant de marquer ma
douce et en commentaire bien évidemment
je vous remercie de me regarder la vidéo
merci d'être toujours plus nombreux
toujours plus présent et s est toujours
plus de lacs et de commentaires c'est
vraiment valorisant parce que quand on
est où ses os à las vegas on bouge pour
aller travailler vous planter de
nouvelles techno et être au coeur de la
high tech c'est hyper gratifiant que
vous soyez là j'ai vraiment à vous en
remercier
je vous invite comme d'habitude a blessé
des jolies pousse à vous abonner pour
reste connecté parce qu'on va reparler
toujours plus les nouveaux produits high
tech et là sur le stand samsung puis
vous assurer qu'il ya des merveilles en
termes des grands c'est incroyable merci
beaucoup à bientôt
ça y est sage ciao
[Musique]